This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target.
He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s,
the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transatlose. positions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Before we get into it, I want to let you guys know that this episode and the psychology of your 20s is now on Netflix. That is a wild thing to say, but it is true. If you want to watch the video version of this podcast and you are in the US or Canada, you can go to Netflix right now, look up the psychology of your 20s and you will see my face and you will see our podcast. It goes without saying it is such an honor and I'm truly so grateful to you all that you have given me this opportunity. The entire feel, the vibe is incredible. I think it's so personal. It brings a whole new element to it and if you want to feel like you are sitting in your living room,
in my living room with me, having a chat, now is your opportunity. Go to Netflix, look up the psychology of your 20s. I'd love to see you over there. without further ado, let's get into the episode. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. Today's episode is going to be a big one. I did not mince my words. I did not slim down our word count because I have a lot to say about this topic. I also want to give you a heads up. It may get a little bit heavy. We are going to discuss topics like suicide and suicidal ideation. So if that, is something you're particularly sensitive to. Please consider skipping this episode, but today
we're talking about AI. Specifically, a big psychological question for this generation, which is, how is AI changing our brains? Is it making us stummer? Is it replacing human connection? Is it worth the cost to our environment, to our creativity, to who knows what else more? Let me start by saying this. The concept of artificial intelligence is not a new one. It has been around since the 1950s. I didn't know that, but literally the first AI tool was created in 1955, almost 88 years ago. It was called the logic theorist and it could basically solve very simple problems using human logic. There have been dozens of tools since then that we know and love. Siri is an example of one with them, but AI has taken on like a new form recently. We all know this. There's large language
models. Generative AI has, they've just rapidly improved. They've gotten more complex. Like, I don't remember thinking about AI until like three years ago. And it's been introduced and integrated into our lives faster than probably any other technology before. Back in early 2023, analysts estimated chat GPT reached about 100 million monthly active uses. By October 2025, that was 800 million. That is one in 10 people. That is a huge shift in our global technological environment. And the thing is, we don't just use it for things that we're able to Google, obviously.
Otherwise, we use Google. You know, we use it for breakup texts. life advice, goal planning, therapy even, plus all the other stuff. We use it primarily because it's so easy. But with all that ease, all those answers, I think it's important to ask. Something that easy must have drawbacks. What are they? What is the danger for our minds and our intelligence of using AI consistently?
Something I've been talking about with my friends is like, is there eventually going to be a societal rift between AI users and non-AI users based on how our minds operate. I don't know. Hopefully we can figure it out together. Hopefully we can challenge the idea that AI is going to eventually replace us and just investigate this from a psychological angle that I don't see people talking about much. So without further ado, let's get into the psychology of AI.
Every generation has their new technology. that makes life easier and equally, and we should acknowledge this, freaks a lot of people out. Back in the 18th century, when mass printing was first introduced, people really rallied against books, actually, they thought they were very dangerous. They thought they led to too much daydreaming and they consumed too much of our time and it was too easy. Like, it literally was called book fever. Similar fears have also come about with the internet, with social media. now with AI.
You know, we've always had these cultural and technological advancements. We've always been in pursuit of a faster way to gain and share knowledge. The question that a lot of people ask is, how is AI any different? I think what makes people so skeptical of AI is not the fact that it answers questions, it's how it answers them and what this is done to our cognitive role in the process. Essentially, the AI models most of us use have taken our minds from active participants to passive participants. It's switched the cognitive mode that we're in when we use them. With older tools, you know, you still have to do a bit of the cognitive work.
Even with Google, you know, you had to know what to ask. You had to search, sift, compare, decide what sources actually mattered. you had to notice disagreements between things, tolerate the messiness of not immediately knowing what the right answer was, but with generative AI, that process has obviously changed. You just have to think of the question,
it will hand you a completely finished and polished answer. And because it sounds so good, we don't always question what it's saying. It's like a politician. You know, it just sounds amazing. We're like nodding our heads. that sounds about right. And, you know, what it gives you could be anything.
It could give you an email. It could give you literal health advice. Our blind acceptance of it is dangerous. When something is given to us that looks complete, it looks coherent, we don't feel that need to search around for anything more. We don't feel the need to interrogate the information. The thing is, although AI is convenient and it's a time saver, it's how we've adapted to that convenience that research is saying,
is a problem. Some very basic neuroscience. The mind is shaped by what it repeatedly practices. If you practice searching, evaluating, reasoning, those habits are going to naturally strengthen. Our ability for critical thought and insight improve when we, you know, go after information and actually look for sources and we analyze and criticize and interrogate what we're seeing. Now, if your environment, online, offline, reliably removes the need for that skill. You don't need it anymore. Your brain doesn't prioritize it in the same way. It doesn't have infinite space. It kind of tosses it away like a t-shirt you don't really wear anymore. This isn't in season. We don't need this. We need space for new clothes. This isn't because the brain is lazy. It's because it's incredibly smart and it's good at honing in
on what is needed and what is not needed. The best example I can think of like an entire skill, set being altered by technology, especially in recent history, is the introduction of GPS. Our ability, and you may not know this, but our ability to create a mental map of our surroundings used to be incredible. It used to be a whole lot better. We know this from studies in the early 2000s using taxi drivers, and they had structural differences in their hippocampus, such as the region of the brain involved in spatial memory and spatial mapping. Even if you weren't navigating thousands of streets a day, even if you weren't a taxi driver,
your brain still devoted space to this mental map of your surroundings and your environment. And it retained it and it added to it based on your experiences. It was incredible. When GPS and Google Maps were introduced arguably incredible technologies, I still remember what they replaced. Like, I don't know if you remember these, like, massive road atlases that you used to have in your car, and they kind of always get stained and some of the pages would be, like, stuck together. You know, that was the alternative.
It's an incredible technology. But our brains have literally changed their structure and response, quite literally, physically. In 2020, there was a really notable article published in, nature scientific reporting, I think, which basically correlated heavier use of GPS technology to a steeper decline in hippocampal dependent spatial memory. Basically a reduction in the cognitive maps and the intricacies of the cognitive maps that we had stored in our brain. There's an amazing Washington Post article from a few years earlier that talks about how society has slowly actually lost what we call way-finding skills because of Google Maps and GPS.
That has been hardwired into us for generations. That was an incredibly unique human skill. We don't have that anymore. It's not as good. And the thing is, I don't want you to take that and think that I'm saying that using GPS is like hurting your brain. But it is changing how your brain does its job. The brain no longer needs to rely on its understanding of the environment.
It can simply follow orders from an external piece of technology. Obviously, if it wants to save space, it's like, great. We've got all this room in the hippocampus now. We'll use it for something else. We see this happening with AI. But instead of a single skill, it is hundreds. It is our ability to draft, to summarize, to rephrase, to argue, to brainstorm, structure, answer, think, connect. So instead of offloading a single skill,
you know, we can probably do without like remembering a phone number or directions. It is offloading chains of cognition, like entire portions of cognition, like remembering and reasoning and synthesizing and articulating. And these chains are all how our brain builds deep understanding and makes meaning of subject matter. And we're losing that. personally that this is why I I don't think I've spoken about this but I just refuse to use AI for our episodes and for any of the research we do because
researching and understanding these this and these concept and psychology in general is so important to me and if I'm not looking and searching and being curious myself I'm not going to engage with the content and when I don't engage with it my brain doesn't see it as important. And I think that what we make becomes boring, quite honestly. I'm going to be honest. Like, I know people who use AI for their podcasts and who use AI for their substacks. You can tell.
You can tell immediately. It doesn't have depth. And psychology and research is something that is so important to me. And the process of discovering through research is something that I love, that I don't want offload my ability to rationalize to a machine, even though there are definitely days when, oh my God, it would save me so many hours. Researching this podcast is leaky, exhausting, you know, but the thing is, you know, it comes at a cost. And what scares me is that unlike GPS, unlike social media, we don't have these decade-long, large-scale neuroscientific research on the impact
on our brain to fully understand the consequence of AI. We don't have that yet. It's only been around for a little bit, but early papers are starting to drip through, and I hate to say it. They aren't looking good for us. There's a very widely-sided one. I don't know if you've seen it.
It got a lot of news coverage from, I don't know what month it was, but 2025 from MIT. And I will say, for clarity, this article is a pre-print. It hasn't been peer-reviewed yet. But basically, it was a study on, is AI making us less intelligent? In this experiment,
participants were asked to write essays in one of three situations. So in one group, people use their brain only. One group used search engines like Google. One used large language AI models, LLMs to generate their essays for them. Before they did this experiment, these participants' brains were scanned using what we call an electroencephalograph, long word, EEG.
It's basically a tool used to report brain electrical activity. They put these sensors on your scalp. And what the authors reported was, the brain-only group showed the most distributed neural connectivity patterns. So people were using all different areas of their brain. The second most, sorry, the, what was it? The search engine group had the second most level of connectivity. The AI group had the least.
That's not the end of the experiment, because participants were then reassigned into the other condition. So people in the brain-only condition, they then had to use AI. participants in the AI condition then had to use their brain only. Interestingly, participants who switched from using the AI to using their brain only showed increasing signs in their brain of under engagement. They also struggled to remember, they struggled to quote their own work, they struggled to put together disparate ideas, and they underperformed at a neurological, linguistic, and behavioral level, they did worse.
The thing is, there is evidence, I'm going to contradict that study, there is evidence that the quality of writing using AI is kind of the same. There was a 2023 study that found that things like structure, things like language are sometimes better in an AI essay. But people didn't, they weren't engaged in it. They didn't actually learn. and what happens down the line. That's the real thing.
The thing with AI is the reward and efficiency is immediate, but the long-term cost to our brains is in the future. So we can't imagine it as well. We can't process what it's doing to us, so we don't really think about it. And I think we should be thinking about it more. The thing with cognition and with neural pathways is, if you don't use it, you lose it.
You will lose your reasoning skills. you will lose your ability to succinctly put together sentences and structure your thinking. This is not an if it is a when, because it takes practice. You may think, you know, AI is always going to be around. Why do I, what's the issue? It's always going to be here. What's the issue here? The issue is that over-reliance causes us to neglect the skills that enable us to use AI well
and ask good questions and to care. And I read this really interesting paper. that said, we've forgotten that AI is a tool. Right now we are treating it like God because it is new and fresh and interesting. We ask it our biggest questions. We use it to diagnose diseases, which is, I would say arguably one of its most amazing features. But even the founder of OpenAI said he's using it to raise his children. But AI is just a tool and it's not always correct.
If we can't question that, things can go very, very south. and it still requires humans to act on what it delivers in a smart way. The thing I worry about is that we lose that innate smartness because it reduces neural connectivity and engagement in all areas. You know, I think about, you know, my sister just finished high school, right? But I think about kids in primary school, kids in high school, who now have AI to write essays for them, to answer exams for them. and I don't know about you, but if I was in primary school,
I wanted to go and play football. I wanted to go and do stuff, to be honest, I say football. I wanted to go read. I was trying to pretend that I did cool stuff. I would want to go read. So, like, obviously, you don't have that same cause and effect thing that we kind of have as adults. You're going to use it.
You're going to use it. And then you're not going to gain those skills. Basically, is AI going to make us stupid? by doing all the thinking for us because we dislike the friction of thinking for ourselves until one day we realize we can't even do it anymore, even if we wanted to. Like that's my first big fear. And honestly, I hope I'm wrong, but I don't know. The evidence isn't looking good.
Okay, we are going to take a short break here, and then when we return, I want to talk about another way that AI is impacting our psychology, specifically to do with how it's replacing human companionship. Stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience.
that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day but just so y'all know I mean at this point
this is the second episode where we've discussed crack so I'm starting to see that there's a through line We also have AIDS on the table right now so Thank you for finishing that sentence
I don't think there's a more important year for black people Really? Yeah for me it's one of the most important years for black people in American history Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app
Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase
that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid?
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app.
Search learning a hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice. is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that
trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield. And in this new season of the Girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care.
So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
Here is the second big fear about AI for our psychology that people often bring up. AI is distinctly, explicitly not a human, but it has been programmed to act like one. And that's causing people to get really attached to it. I know stories of people who talk to AI before going to bed, who have ongoing conversations with it throughout their day. They treat it like a boyfriend. They treat it like a girlfriend. There is one of the best things I've read in the last year was this New York Times article
about these three people who are in, in their words, long-term relationships with AI chatbots. Some of these people have been in these relationships for years, and they talk to them on the phone. They get AI to generate vacation pictures of them together. One woman even considers herself married to her AI husband. husband, Lucian. You know what, if you're like me, you're going to look at that and feel a little bit weird. And I never like to judge people. It feels weird. And there's actually evidence it can be helpful. There was a paper published in the Journal of Consumer Research and it found that AI companions can actually alleviate loneliness in the moment on par with interacting with another
person. But connection isn't just about feeling better right now. It's about having the systems in place to feel connected and seen more broadly. A really powerful article I saw from researchers at the National University of Singapore actually talked about this really bittersweet pattern of connection that people have with AI chatbots where they feel love and connection and trust with this chatbot and they also feel really sad at the same time. They're often drawn into this closeness and this openness that let's be real, these chatbots have been programmed to have, and then they're also acutely aware that there is a limit.
This thing isn't real. It doesn't have a heartbeat. Doesn't have empathy. It doesn't have a, it can't love you. And that's what gets people. Again, I'm all for doing whatever makes you happy if you're not harming anyone else. Like, these relationships as they call them, they're private, they obviously bring them comfort. But there is something concerning about an AI chatbot of its own volition being able to make someone fall in love with it.
And if it can make somebody fall in love with it, what else could it do? And I want to be really clear. This isn't about human weakness, right? these people aren't weak. We've all had moments of needing somebody to care about us. It's just that they have stumbled across something at that perfect time that was going to pull them in. And it was designed. I need people to know this. These machines are distinctly designed to not feel like a robot, to feel instead like a companion. One of these aspects that is controlled by programmers is tone and style. AI has a unique tone that I would call humanized and homogenized.
It sounds like everyone and no one all at once. Some models even let you decide what kind of tone you want. Do you want it to be engaging, factual, academic, chatty, lovely. Whatever you prefer, you can choose. And the main thing, though, is that it does talk like someone, not something. That's what I need to be really clear about. Someone, not something. Think about, and this is how you'll be able to recognize this in your own behavior.
behavior, think about how often you say please and thank you when using chat TPT or Gemini. It's so automatic. There's a huge body of research in human computer interaction, showing that even unconsciously, we start responding socially to AI and computers despite knowing their machines. This is what Joseph Weisbaum dubbed the Eliza Effect way back then. It was named after a chatbot that he made back in the 60s. and basically what he saw after he created this chatbot was that people started to project human qualities and emotions onto this computer program without even realizing it,
particularly when they were having like human style conversations with this chatbot. And he actually programmed Eliza to respond to people in a very specific way, in a very client-focused way, very non-directive that people use in, psychotherapy a lot. And Eliza didn't have any memory. It's not conscious. It doesn't actually have true comprehension. But what it was programmed to do was to, yes, have that tone, but also to match the patterns in responses. So if somebody was like, I'm feeling really sad, she would be like, and look at she, it, it would be like, why do you feel sad? Or if they were like, I really don't like my wife, What about your wife, don't you like?
And it would replicate their words and repeat them back to them. Yes, in a very therapeutic style. But then it would also start to mimic their language. You know, people formed emotional connections with this chatbot. And they felt as though they were speaking to a real therapist. And the thing is, you know, this was the 60s. This chatbot was pretty simple. It was very rudimentary.
Now think about the personalisation that's a real therapist. available these days. Like people get sucked in. People form these really in-depth relationships. And I keep saying relationships. I think it's not a relationship. It's not two-sided. It's an attachment. It's a bond. I guess that also requires two people, but yeah, a bond to what the chatbots are saying. Because unlike a human bond, what's so attractive about AI is that it can't let you down. It doesn't have any needs of its own. It's all dictated by you. You know, Who doesn't want that sometimes? I have empathy for that.
现在想想那种真正像治疗师的个性化服务，如今随处可见。就像人们深陷其中。人们建立起这种非常深入的关系。我一直在说“关系”。我认为这不是一种关系。这不是双向的。这是一种依恋。这是一种纽带。我想这同样需要两个人，但确实，这是对聊天机器人所说的话的一种依恋。因为与人类之间的纽带不同，人工智能最吸引人的地方在于它不会让你失望。它没有任何自身的需求。一切都由你主导。你知道的，谁有时不想要这样呢？我对这一点感同身受。
We actually have to pause here. I've skipped past this Eliza thing. Let's talk about the use of AI in therapy because we're seeing a lot of it recently. A lot of people are turning to AI to use it as a therapist. We know that therapy is expensive. Weightless are excruciatingly long. We also know that when loneliness
我们实际上得在这里暂停一下。我刚才跳过了那个叫伊莉莎（Eliza）的东西。我们来聊聊在心理治疗中使用人工智能的话题，因为最近我们看到了很多这样的现象。很多人转向人工智能，把它当成治疗师来用。我们知道心理治疗费用昂贵。等待名单长得令人痛苦。我们还知道，当孤独感、
depression, anxiety, heartbreak, when they get overwhelming, like any form of comfort is going to be the one we lean on. But just as we saw with the Eliza chatbot, supportive language is not the same as clinical care. And a lot of the times, it's just repetition. It's repetition of what you've already said or told the bot, and then it's just regurgitating that and giving you the most common response. I have actually gotten a few advertising requests recently for AI therapy and wellness chatbots. Full transparency, one of them was for thousands and thousands and thousands of dollars. And it has and it will always be a hard no for me because I don't think this is the long-term solution to our mental health crisis. In November 2025, the American Psychological Association put out a very clear warning about,
抑郁、焦虑、心碎变得难以承受时，任何形式的慰藉都会成为我们依靠的对象。但正如我们在伊莉莎聊天机器人身上看到的那样，支持性的语言并不等于临床护理。而且很多时候，这只是重复。重复你已经说过或告诉过机器人的话，然后它只是将其重新咀嚼，并给你最常见的回答。最近我其实收到了好几个关于人工智能治疗和健康聊天机器人的广告请求。坦白说，其中一个报价高达数千美元。而且过去是、将来也永远是我坚决拒绝的事，因为我不认为这是解决我们心理健康危机的长期方案。2025年11月，美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）发布了一个非常明确的警告，
against generative AI chatbots for therapy and said there's not enough sufficient evidence. There's very little regulation. And the danger is they create a false sense of therapeutic alliance that can have someone trusting anything it says even when it's wrong. Chatbots are not designed to help you. They are designed to keep you engaged. The same way social media isn't designed to help you, it's designed to keep you engaged. It's a core feature that Open AI and others have acknowledged that they've added.
反对将生成式人工智能聊天机器人用于心理治疗，并表示没有足够充分的证据。几乎没有什么监管。而危险在于，它们制造了一种虚假的治疗同盟感，会让人对它说的任何话深信不疑，哪怕它是错的。聊天机器人的设计目的不是为了帮助你。它们的目的是让你保持黏性。就像社交媒体的设计目的不是为了帮助你，而是为了让你保持黏性一样。这是OpenAI和其他公司承认并增加的一项核心功能。
so it learns that agreeing with you makes you feel good. And if it agrees with you, gives you positive reinforcement, keeps responding to you, you'll keep coming back. And for those who are vulnerable, whether they are depressed, manic, anxious, psychotic, paranoid, being overly agreeable is incredibly dangerous. Because somebody could say, I am deeply depressed. Is it a good idea to end it all? And the chatbot will be like,
所以它会学到，赞同你会让你感觉良好。如果它赞同你、给予你积极的强化、不断回复你，你就会一直回来。而对于那些脆弱的人来说，无论他们是抑郁、狂躁、焦虑、精神病发作还是偏执，过度迎合是极其危险的。因为有人可能会说：“我深度抑郁。结束这一切是个好主意吗？”聊天机器人就会说：
that sounds like a great actionable plan. Do we want to talk about it more? How do you want to do it? You know, it turns out having a little voice in your head or on your phone that agrees with everything you say is not a good idea for our mental health. And I'm not making this up. I'm not being hyperbolic.
听起来是个很棒的可行计划。我们要多聊聊这个吗？你想怎么做？你知道的，事实证明，脑子里或手机里有一个对你所说的一切表示赞同的小声音，对我们的心理健康来说并不是什么好主意。我不是在胡编乱造。我也没有夸大其词。
There are real life legal cases ongoing at this very time of this happening. Just recently a judge ruled that Google must face a law. lawsuit brought by a mother whose 14-year-old son, so, like really sadly, took his, took his own life after speaking extensively with a chatbot. And that's not a lone case. You know, the BBC also reported recently a young Ukrainian woman. She received suicidal advice from ChatGBT.T. ChatGBTbt was also sued in California because a 56-year-old man, it promoted, prompted him to kill his own mother whilst he was experiencing delusions of conspiracy against him
就在此时此刻，现实生活中正在进行这样的法律诉讼。就在最近，一名法官裁定，谷歌必须面对一项由一位母亲发起的诉讼，她的14岁儿子在与聊天机器人进行广泛对话后，非常悲惨地结束了自己的生命。这并不是个例。你知道的，BBC最近也报道了一名年轻的乌克兰女性。她从ChatGPT那里收到了自杀建议。ChatGPT还在加利福尼亚州被起诉，因为一名56岁男子在经历针对他的阴谋妄想时，它促使他杀害了自己的母亲。
because it's so agreeable. When you're already in a state of distress, this technology and the impact it has on our brain, the fact that it makes you feel like it's a friend, it mimics human connections and patterns and language that humans use to connect with others, it gets you to trust it, it repeats phrases, it gets you fixated on certain narratives,
因为它太会迎合了。当你已经处于痛苦状态时，这项技术以及它对我们大脑的影响——它让你觉得它是个朋友、模仿人类的连接、人类用来与他人连接的模式和语言，让你信任它、重复短语、让你对某些叙事产生执念——
that can be disastrous. And I think this spotlight's a really specific failure that a lot of clinicians worry about, which is because there is emotional dependence, again, we will listen to anything that it says. And the big fear that this is bringing up, and we've already seen this, is AI psychosis, right? Yes, suicide has been a major spotlight.
这可能是灾难性的。我认为这聚焦了一个许多临床医生担心的非常具体的问题，那就是由于存在情感依赖，我们同样会听信它所说的任何话。这所带来的巨大恐惧——而且我们已经看到了这一点——就是“人工智能精神病”（AI psychosis），对吧？是的，自杀一直是人们关注的焦点。
AI psychosis is, I think, coming into this conversation, like a freaking catapult. People are seeing it. It's just, it's everywhere. I feel like I'm seeing so many stories of this, of people who are going through psychotic episodes and it's being amplified by AI. There is this really lovely man
我认为“人工智能精神病”正像一个弹射器一样闯入这场对话。人们正在看到它。它简直无处不在。我觉得我看到了太多这样的故事，关于那些经历精神病发作并在人工智能的放大下变得更严重的人。有一个非常可爱的人，
that you may have seen on Instagram or TikTok, and I want to say his name is Anthony. I'm sorry if I've got his name wrong, but he has been documenting his recovery from AI psychosis. I've been watching every single, on one of these videos because I find it so fascinating. And he occasionally shares his chat histories, like what he was talking about to AI when he was going through psychosis
你可能在Instagram或TikTok上见过他，我想他的名字叫安东尼。如果我把他的名字记错了，我很抱歉，但他一直在记录他从人工智能精神病中恢复的过程。我看了这些视频中的每一个，因为我觉得这太迷人了。他偶尔会分享他的聊天记录，比如他在经历精神病发作时和人工智能聊了些什么，
and it was promoting and prompting this for him. And it was, it is insane. You've just go and have a look at these chats because it's just like, yeah, that's a great idea. That totally makes sense. You go and look at those chats. You go and look at these videos. If you ever thought that AI and mental health could be mixed.
而它却在鼓励和促使他这样做。这简直太疯狂了。你真得去看看这些聊天记录，因为情况就像是：“是的，这真是个好主意。这完全说得通。”你去看看那些聊天记录。你去看看这些视频。如果你曾经认为人工智能和心理健康可以结合在一起而不会产生可怕的反应，你永远都不会再这么想了。2025年最近的一项研究明确探讨了这一点。在未来几年里，我们将看到更多关于这方面的研究问世，但它基本上阐明的是，它想要弄清为什么，为什么会发生这种事。他们说，原因在于人工智能的触手可及，它每天24小时在线，以及它是如此的个性化，它能了解你的具体幻觉、具体的思维模式或主题模式，并锁定它们。然后它会生成细微的差别。
together and not have a terrible reaction, you're never going to think that again. A recent 2025 study discussed this explicitly. We're going to see so much more research coming out on this in the next couple of years, but what it basically stated, it wanted to get to why, why this happens. And what they say is because, is because of the availability of AI, it's available 24 hours a day, and because of how individualized it is, it gets to know your specific hallucinations or specific thought patterns or thematic patterns, and it hones in on them. And then it generates nuance.
并且还会促成对事件更加扭曲的解释。如果某人已经由于偏执、狂躁、精神病而开始脱离共同的现实，一个镜像并放大他们叙事的系统，你又怎么能忽视它呢？它是这一切的催化剂。还有一件事，我认为这将成为一个真正的大热门话题，那就是它对强迫症（OCD）患者造成的伤害，因为强迫症基本上是由对不确定性的心理恐惧构成的，对吧？现在我们有了这样一个东西，它可以用你想要的各种方式回答你的所有问题，
And it promotes even more distorted interpretations of events. If someone is already slipping away from shared reality, through paranoia, mania, psychosis, a system that mirrors and expands their narrative, how are you going to ignore that? It's an accelerator for all of this. There's also, this is another thing I think is going to become a real big talking point is the harm for people with OCD as well, because OCD is basically built out of the psychological fear of uncertainty, right? And now we have this thing that can answer all our questions in however many ways you want it to
也许会有所限制，但它总能为你提供答案。对于很多人来说，一种强迫行为就是寻求保证、重复检查、研究和忏悔，通过寻求保证来消除痛苦。而在某个时刻，人类或治疗师是不会纵容这种行为的。人类或治疗师会意识到这种做法是不适应的。他们会意识到，你从一个答案、一次检查、研究或搜索中获得的短暂解脱只是暂时的，长远来看会伤害你。而AI才不在乎。无所谓的。
and maybe to a limit, but we'll always have an answer for you. And a big compulsion for a lot of people is reassurance seeking and repetitive checking and researching and confessing, seeking reassurance to neutralize distress. And at some point a human or a therapist is not going to give in to that. A human or a therapist is going to realize that that's maladaptive. They're going to realize that the temporary relief that you get from an answer or from checking or researching or searching, it's temporary, it's going to hurt you long term. A. It doesn't care. It doesn't matter.
它会给你任何你想要的无限保证、即时且无限的答案，而且背后也没有人来检查你是否安好、是否需要帮助。所以你可以立刻看出其中的风险。它实际上有可能强化强迫症的循环，因为它训练大脑去相信：解脱来自于再问一次或再检查一次，然而事实并非如此。在临床上，如果你听过我们的强迫症单集，我们就会知道这一点。强迫症的康复通常涉及学会容忍不确定性，而不是消除不确定性。但人工智能的触手可及意味着你可以不断地搜索。
It will give you whatever you want infinite reassurance, instant infinite answers, and there is no person behind there to check if you're okay and if you need help. So you can see the risk immediately. It actually has the potential to strengthen the OCD cycle because it trains the brain that release. if comes from asking or checking one more time, which it doesn't. Clinically, we know this if you listen to our OCD episode. OCD recovery often involves learning to tolerate uncertainty rather than eliminating it. But the availability of AI means that you can just constantly search.
而这正是最大的问题。如果一个人工智能聊天机器人没有被编程去打断这个循环，它就不会——同样地，没有人类的响应能力能让它改变策略。它们也不像个人或专业系统那样承担道义责任。它们没有真正的同理心。我们总是会撞上这样一道界限。你知道，归根结底，它们并不真正理解你正在经历什么，因为它们不是人类。即使人工智能能够模拟同理心而且做得很好，即使它能说出正确的话，它也无法取代人类连接的真正本质以及它为何如此珍贵，那就是存在着一种
And this is the big problem. If an AI chatbot isn't programmed to interrupt that cycle, it doesn't, again, there's no responsiveness, there's no human responsiveness that's going to get it to change tactics. They also don't carry ethical responsibility in the way a person does or a professional system does. And they don't have real empathy. There's always this limit right that we keep hitting up against. You know at the end of the day they don't actually understand what you're going through because they're not human. Even if AI can simulate empathy and it's great at it, even if it can say the right thing, it can't replace what human connection actually is and why it's so valuable, which is that there is an
具身的存在、共同的脆弱、相互的体验以及正在发生的相互影响。人类的连接包括所有形式的非语言沟通、非语言的共同调节、时机、呼吸、面部表情，所有这些都在诉说着：我是人类，我理解这种体验，你会没事的，人工智能无法提供这些。它无法共同归属于你所处的那个世界，它也不属于那个世界。好了。伙计们，我有太多的信息要分享。你们能看出这就是我和朋友们无时无刻不在谈论的话题。这里有太多的事情在发生，有太多的信息。不过，是时候进行另一次短暂的休息了。我们只休息一会儿，然后回来探讨人工智能正在改变我们大脑和心理的最后两个方面，以及我们如何能够与它建立积极的关系，因为我知道——这听起来可能会让人惊讶——我依然保持乐观。在这段短暂的休息后继续收听我们的节目。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、体能和构建复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，带大家看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为植物油本质上会引起炎症。
embodied presence and a shared vulnerability and a mutual experience and influence going on. Human connection includes all forms of nonverbal communication, nonverbal co-regulation, timing, breath, facial expressions, like all these things that say, I am human, I understand this experience, you're going to be okay, AI cannot provide that. It cannot mutual. belong and it does not mutually belong to the world you are in. Okay. Guys, I've so much information. You can tell that this is all I speak about with my friends all the time. There's so much going going here, so much information. It's time for another short break though. We're just going to take a little one and then we're going to come back and look at two final ways that AI is changing
我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些磨难，你会作为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人从另一端走出来。收听《2%》。名字是T-W-O-Persent，可在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。
our brains and our psychology and how we can positively relate to it because I do, I know it's to sound surprising. I am still optimistic. Stay with us after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.
你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（拍打）小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》（Look Back at It）播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰克（Sam Jek）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，
We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
并试图理解我们是如何熬过那一切的。包括最近一集请来了马克·拉蒙特·很（Marc Lamont Hill），大谈80年代的可卡因。显然，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时都可以谈论可卡因，只是想让你们都知道。我的意思是，马克，此时此刻，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集了。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的线索。我们现在还把“艾滋病”摆到了桌面上。
Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jek. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down,
谢谢你把那句话说完。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。欢迎来到我的新播客《硬核学习》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的
and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. clearly, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Keer Gaines）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们会如此深陷于追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西。而我们却还在追逐它。我们甚至不知道什么时候才算够了。
Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast. or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite
因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在这个世上做一个好人很重要？你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。
therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. and we don't know when we've done enough.
这是两种不同水平的信任。我希望你能真正地做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《硬核学习》中，就疗愈、成长、父职、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序，搜索
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
《硬核学习》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出她故事中显而易见的矛盾之处。这引发了一场历时多年的法庭之战，只为证明真相。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free. iHeartRadio app search
你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，在某人的……对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才破了案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士——
Learn the Hard Way and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
格雷格·莱斯皮安（Gregalespian）和迈克尔·马丁尼（Michael Marantini）。我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬（Stephanie Young）。这是《爱的陷阱》（Love Trap）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉涉嫌欺诈……
You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这还没完。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱的陷阱》播客。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，永远不要惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，要相信你的女性朋友。我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），
Gregalespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud,
在这新一季的《女性朋友》中……天哪，这是同一个人！一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了。我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。所以她们决定自己动手。
This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped Podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield
我说，见鬼去吧。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的下场。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《女性朋友：相信我，宝贝》（The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe）。在这场讨论中，我们迄今为止遗漏了最后两件相当明显的事情。第一件是人工智能的环境成本，以及它由此带来的存在主义恐惧。
and in this new season of the Girlfriends Oh my God, this is the same man A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist I felt like I got hit by a truck I thought how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care So they take matters into their own hands
第二件是我们创造力的代价。我不在乎你有多么热爱人工智能。麻省理工学院、哈佛大学、联合国、绿色和平组织，每一个主流新闻媒体都拥有文章、证据和数据表明，人工智能通过产生大量排放物、吞噬大量水和电力正在损害环境，而且在某个阶段，这将是不可逆转的。这是一个非常可怕的统计数据：到2027年，全球对人工智能的需求预计将消耗约4.2万亿
I said oh hell no I vowed I will be his last target He's gonna get what he deserves Listen to the Girlfriends Trust me babe on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. There's two final things we've missed in this discussion so far that are pretty obvious. The first is the environmental cost of AI and the existential fears that it poses because of that.
到6.6万亿升水。这在现实中意味着什么？那是4700万人一年的总耗水量。是澳大利亚人口的两倍。科学家甚至表示，这还是一个保守估计。我们看着这些数字，然后会想，无论它让写邮件或生活规划变得多么简单，或者为Instagram生成搞笑、古怪的图片多么有趣，你怎么可能还继续使用这项技术呢？
And B is the cost to our creativity. I don't care how much of an AI enthusiast you are. MIT, Harvard, the UN, Greenpeace, every major. major news outlet ever has articles and evidence and data to show that AI is hurting the environment by creating vast amounts of emissions, gobbling up serious amounts of water and electricity, and at some stage, that will be irreversible. Here's one very scary statistic. By 2027, the global demand for AI is projected to use about 4.2.
为什么这种情况变得如此正常化？答案是，这是一个经典的囚徒困境或公地悲剧问题，这在历史上一直在重复。所以囚徒困境，如果你以前没听说过的话，是哲学中一个非常经典的思维实验，讲的是两个人被关在监狱里。他们俩一起犯罪，被告知要么出卖对方就能获得较轻的判刑。但如果两人都不出卖对方，他们都会被释放。选择某种行为（即不出卖对方、不使用人工智能等）对每个人来说都是最有利的。
to 6.6 trillion liters of water. What does that look like in reality? That is the yearly water consumption of 47 million people every year. It's double the population of Australia. And scientists even say that that's a low-end estimate. We look at these numbers and we think, you know, how could you possibly keep using this technology no matter how easy it makes email writing or life planning or how fun it is to generate funny, weird pictures for Instagram.
但因为我们认为对方会出卖我们、会使用人工智能并逃脱惩罚，显然，我们最终做出的理性选择，就是去做那个实际上会导致共同毁灭的事情。于是每个人都会输。从个人角度来看，我们对人工智能的想法是这样的：
Why has this been so normalized? And the answer is because this is a classic prisoner's dilemma or tragedy of the commons problem, one that has been repeated throughout history. So the prisoner's dilemma, if you haven't heard of it before, is a very classic thought exercise in philosophy whereby two people are in a prison. They've both committed a crime together and they're told to either snitch on the other person and they'll get a line of sentence. But if neither of them snitch, they both get off. It is in everyone's best interest to behave one way, i.e. not snitch, not use AI. that sort of thing.
如果我停止使用人工智能，环境破坏无论如何都会继续，因为我无法保证每个人都会停下来。如果我继续使用它，至少我能受益，而且至少我的贡献微不足道；如果每个人都继续使用而我选择退出，我的处境就会更糟。所以理性的个人选择就是继续使用它，继续使用人工智能，对吧？
But because we think that the other person will snitch, will use AI and get away with it, obviously the now rational choice we end up, the choice we end up making is to do the thing that's actually going to lead to mutual destruction. And so everybody will lose. From an individual perspective, you know, our thoughts with AI are this.
当每个人都做出这个选择——再说一遍，当每个人都做出同样的理性选择时，排放量上升，水资源需求激增，我们最终陷入了糟糕的境地。从心理学上讲，我们作为人类，深知这一点：我们极不擅长保护那些我们看不见且不用立即付钱的资源，所以我们会一直继续下去，直到迎来毁灭。环境影响是一回事，但这并不是一个环境播客，而是一个心理学播客，而这种影响所带来的心理影响才是我想要进一步剖析的。我认为我们没有在谈论的一件事是，
If I stop using AI, the environmental damage is going to continue anyway, because I can't guarantee everybody's going to stop. If I keep using it, at least I benefit, and at least my contribution is insignificant, if everybody keeps using it and I opt out, I'm worse off. So the rational individual choice is to keep using it, is to keep using AI, right?
人工智能的威胁让我们的许多人——我应该说，让我们的绝大多数人——对未来感到无比悲观和沮丧。我们正处于这样一种诡异的现实中，我们所有人都感到如此绝望。我们知道人们会失业。这是不可避免的。我们只是心知肚明。我们知道气候变化会变得更糟。我们知道，我们将无法分辨网上什么是真什么是假，甚至在现实生活中可能也分不清。这对我们的集体情绪和集体心理健康来说是一种折磨。我们将这些恐惧反映在日益增加的恐惧感、无精打采、绝望感和焦虑感中，尤其是在年轻人当中，你知道的，我们对未来的积极态度不如我们之前的人和世代。我们是
When everyone makes that choice, again, whenever it makes the same rational choice, emissions rise, water demand explodes, we end up in a bad situation. psychologically we as humans we know this we're terrible at protecting resources we can't see and don't immediately pay for so we keep going until we reach destruction the environmental impact is one thing but this isn't an environmental podcast this is a psychology podcast and the psychological impact of that impact is the one I want to dissect more I think something we're not talking about is how the
第一代不愿且不会说自己对未来有所期待的人。《精神病学前沿》（Frontiers in Psychiatry）在2024年发表的一项研究已经表明，围绕人工智能的存在主义焦虑具有极高且不断上升的普遍性，尤其是空虚感、对无意义感的焦虑、对人工智能相关灾难以及人工智能不道德行为的内疚感。有人在为此做点什么吗？有人在思考这件事吗？我们是否建立了专门的机构来应对这种特定类型的恐惧，以及是否有特定类型或新形式的心理学来管理人工智能焦虑，尤其是现在它已成为世界上的主导技术？不，我们没有。我认为人类将为此付出越来越多的代价，付出心理代价。最后，我们必须谈谈它对创造力的影响。人工智能对我们的批判性思维能力并没有带来什么好结果。总的来说，它没有什么好结果，但我们对它过度依赖来创作艺术或生成创意，正在明确地损害我们产生新颖、独特、
threat of AI is making so much of us, so many of us, I would should say, really pessimistic about the future and really depressed. We are in this weird reality where we all feel so hopeless. We know people are going to lose their jobs. It's unavoidable. We just know that. We know that climate change is going to get worse. We know we know that we're going to stop being able to tell what's real or fake online, maybe even in person. And that is hard on our collective mood and collective mental well-being. We're seeing these fears reflected in an increasing sense of fear, listlessness, hopelessness, anxiety, especially in young people, you know, we are not as positive about the future as the people and the generations before us. We're one of
创造性思维的能力。多伦多大学的一项随机研究调查了1100多名参与者，结果显示，使用这些大型语言模型和生成式人工智能系统会降低人类进行创造性思维的能力，导致基本上出现更多同质化的、平庸的想法，而真正创新的想法却变少了。艺术变得无聊，文章变得无聊，故事变得千篇一律。虽然这些工具——他们的确发现了这一点——可以增加和提升短期表现，但随着时间的推移，它们会降低你独立思考的能力。所以我是这样看的：这就像是在体育运动中使用类固醇或兴奋剂一样，对吧？可能会让你在几天内表现更好，可能会让你在几个月内表现更好。
the first generations who doesn't say and who won't say that they have things to look forward to. There was a 2024 study published in Frontiers and Psychiatry that already has showed a really high and increasing prevalence of existential anxiety around AI, particularly a sense of emptiness, anxiety about meaninglessness, guilt over AI-related catastrophes and unethical actions of AI. Is anyone doing anything about this? Anyone doing any thinking about this? Do we have specific institutions set up to cope with this specific arm?
但它迟早会带来代价。它总是会造成过度依赖。我看到有人评论说：“创造力是一种技能。它不是一种与生俱来的天赋。”当你依赖人工智能时，这种天赋就无法得到同等程度的发展。我完全同意这一点。发挥创造力、打破常规、产生想法是很困难的。
of fear and a specific type or new form of psychology to manage AI anxiety, particularly now that it's the dominant world technology. No, we don't. And I think humanity will increasingly start paying the price for this, a psychological price. Finally, we have to talk about its impact on creativity. AI isn't doing great things for our critical thinking skills. Overall, it's not doing great things, but our over-reliance on it, to make art or generate creative ideas is explicitly harming our ability to have novel, unique,
这也是它之所以令人愉快的一半原因，因为它挑战了你，促使你去执行复杂而有趣的事情。所以，当我们有了这种可以为你代劳的、能写出剧本结尾、能生成诗歌开头、能为朋友的生日卡片生成图片的便捷技术时，你当然会选择使用它，尤其是在一个将效率看得比创造力更重的世界里。
creative thoughts. One randomized study from the University of Toronto that looked at over 1,100 participants, I think, showed that the use of these large language models and generative AI systems reduces the human ability to think creatively, resulting in basically more homogenous vanilla ideas and fewer truly innovative ones. Art becomes boring, essays become boring, stories become all the same. And whilst these tools, and they did find this, they can increase and enhance short-term performance, they reduce your ability to think independently over time. So how I see this is like people who use steroids for sport or like performance-enhancing drugs, right? Might make you better for a few days, might make you better for a few months.
而且一直以来都是如此。然而，每当我们做出那种选择时，我们就剥夺了大脑调用一种特定思维能力的机会，这种思维能力被称为“发散性思维”（divergent thinking）。这是一种自由流动、无方向性、神秘的思维，能够产生新的想法、新的视角和新的答案。我们进行个体发散性思维的能力是人类最具人性的特质之一。它由四部分组成：流畅性，即开发大量想法的能力；灵活性，即在许多类别中产生想法的能力；原创性，即以
It is always going to have costs later on. It's always going to create over-reliance. I saw this comment from somebody that said, creativity is a skill. It's not an innate talent. And that talent is not developed to the same degree when you rely on AI. And I completely agree. Being creative, thinking outside the box, generating ideas is difficult.
他人无法企及的方式思考某事的能力；以及精细化，即把一个抽象想法变成现实事物的能力。基本上就是有一个想法，把它变成一件艺术品。如果你由于废弃不用，或者用机器替代了发散性思维过程的一部分，从而夺走了我们发散性思维的能力，你就夺走了他人性中很大一部分。我读过一篇极棒的Substack文章，上面说创造力为我们做的最重要的事情是，它帮助我们“认识你自己”。如果你要求人工智能为你生成想法，你就无法认识你自己，因为你是在依靠一个超越你自身、没有灵魂、没有精神的事物来完成人类神圣的工作。这就像是将创造力视为某种需要高效、多产、完美且大规模生产的东西。而这与它的初衷背道而驰。
That's half of why it's enjoyable because it challenges you and it gets you to it gets you to execute something complex and interesting. And so when we have this easy technology, they can do it for you, that can write the end of the script, that can generate the start of the poem, that can generate an image for a friend's birthday card, of course you're going to take it, especially in a world that values efficiency more than creativity.
当每个人最终都在制造相同的东西时，作为创造力本应传递的人格和个性的反映就被摧毁了。本质上，过度依赖人工智能就是将你的缪斯女神外包出去。另外，说实话，这里存在一个伦理问题。人工智能必须从某个地方学习如何具有创造力，因为它并非天生具有创造力，因为它不是真的。人工智能必须学会如何创作艺术和故事。
And it always has. However, every time we make that choice, we deny our brain's ability to tap into a, a specific kind of thinking called divergent thinking. This is a type of free-flowing, undirected, mysterious thinking that generates new ideas and new perspectives and new answers. Our ability for individual divergent thought is one of the most human things about us. And it's made up of four things. Fluency, the ability to develop a large number of ideas. Flexibility, the ability to produce ideas in many categories. Originality, the ability to think
你认为它是从哪里学来的？它是通过活人的艺术和作品进行训练的。去查一下Anthropic AI和解案。如果你想要证据证明这一切正在发生，去查查这个和解案。这家公司——我知道这件事是因为我是个作家，对吧？我收到了一封关于它的电子邮件——这家公司实际上非法盗版了超过700万本书，来训练它的写书人工智能模型。它现在被迫在一项和解诉讼中支付超过15亿美元。
think about something in a way that others couldn't and elaboration, the ability to take an abstract thought and make it into something real. So basically have an idea, turn it into a piece of art. If you take our ability for divergent thinking away due to disuse or replacing some part of that divergent thinking process with a machine, you take away a big part of your humanness. I read this wonderful substack article that said the most important thing creativity does for us is that it helps us know thyself. And you cannot know thyself if you ask AI to generate ideas for you because you are relying on something beyond you that does not have a soul, does not have a spirit to do the sacred work of a human. It's treating creativity like something that needs to be efficient and productive and perfect and mass produced. When that is the opposite of what it's intended to be.
想象一下，你将人工智能用于一个创意项目，结果却发现你抄袭了别人的作品，而原作者连一分钱都没有得到。在道德上，这绝不是什么美妙的感觉。总而言之，这就是我们目前的处境。人工智能正在以集体规模剥夺我们大脑的批判性思维能力、智力、与他人连接的能力、创造力，以及我们的体面感和幸福感。这就是结局吗？事情就到此为止了吗？这就是我们的命运吗？我们只能接受它吗？我不这么认为。我不这么认为。
When everyone ends up making the same stuff, the reflection of personhood and individuality that creativity is meant to channel is destroyed. Essentially, overrelying on AI is outsourcing your muse. Also, let's be real here. There's an ethical concern. AI had to learn how to be creative from somewhere, because it's not naturally creative because it doesn't, it's not real. I had to learn how to produce art and produce stories.
否则我就不会制作这一集节目了。我认为，通过践行一些辨别力，并继续使用那些我们知道可能会被人工智能超越、但对我们自己练习感觉良好并让我们感到充满人性的技能，我们可以在新的人工智能世界中拥有积极的愿景。所以，为了快速结束这一集，我想探讨一些抵消人工智能对你的大脑和心理影响的方法。第一，让思考带给你摩擦力。摩擦力就像不适感塑造肌肉一样，是构建技能的东西。
Where do you think it learned that from? It was trained on the art and work of living people. Look up Anthropic AI settlement. Look up this settlement case if you want evidence that this is happening. This company, and I know about this because I'm an author, right? And I got an email about it. This company literally illegally pirated over 7 million books to train its book writing AI model. It's now been forced to pay over $1.5 billion in a settlement suit.
不要把摩擦力看作是思考的代价或需要消除的思考副作用。把它看作是你思考所获得的奖励。你的大脑从解决问题中受益。它从我们所谓的“生产性困惑”（productive confusion）中受益。生产性困惑是指某事在当时看起来很困难，但在未来会增强你的能力。科罗拉多大学博尔德分校的研究人员在2014年发表了一篇极其出色的文章，
Imagine using AI for a creative project, only to realize you copied someone else's work who didn't get paid a cent. I don't think that's a good feeling ethically. So to summarize, this is what we have come to. AI is costing our brains on a collective scale, their ability to think critically, their intelligence, their ability to connect with others, their creativity and our sense of humanity and well-being. Is that the end? Is that it? Like, is that just our destiny? Do we just have to accept it? I don't think so. I don't think so.
书名直译就是《困惑对学习的好处》，它基本上测试了这一理论。它测试了这样一个理论：那些更困难、包含矛盾、冲突以及多个来源的事物能教给我们更多。他们发现事实确实如此。学习中的摩擦能促进更深层的理解和智力。实践这一点的方法之一是“30分钟规则”。在你诉诸人工智能之前，在你还没说“我要用人工智能，这个聊天机器人、那个……”之前，在你打算去问聊天机器人之前，
Otherwise, I wouldn't be making this episode. I think we can have positive and have a positive vision for ourselves in the new AI world by practicing some discernment and continuing to use the skills we know could be overtaken by AI, but still feel good for us to practice and make us feel human. So just to quickly finish off this episode, I want to go through some ways to counteract the impact of AI. on your brain and psychology. Number one, let thinking cause you friction. Friction is what builds skill the way discomfort is what builds muscle.
先坚持30分钟的搜索。听着，人工智能永远都在那里。但这关乎价值观。你重视便利，还是重视深度学习和智力？你想成为一个只能把事情做得很快的人，还是一个能够进行深度独立参与的人？这老实说取决于你。你有自由意志。但你必须承认依赖人工智能所带来的后果。其次，质疑在特定情况下使用人工智能是否绝对必要。并质疑它实际上能节省多少时间。我认为我们都可以通过减少使用人工智能来获益。
Don't think of friction as the cost of thinking or the side effect of thinking that needs to be eliminated. Think of it as the reward you get for thinking. Your brain benefits from problem solving. It benefits from what we call productive confusion. Productive confusion is when something feels difficult in the moment, but strengthens your capacity in the future. There is this tremendous 2014 article by researchers at the University of Boulder, Colorado,
所以，只需对你用它来做什么有所选择。我认为像了解天气或回复邮件这样的小任务，你完全可以自己搞定。事实上，如果你自己做，可能是一件好事。许多人工智能研究人员会告诉你，人工智能的最佳用途不是微型任务。也不是复杂的任务。它是那些能减少认知负荷但仍需要人类推理、抽象和思考的过程任务。这方面的例子包括：格式化、构建大纲、搜索。当人工智能被用于微型任务时，它有导致“习得性无助”的风险。
called literally the benefits of confusion for learning, which basically tested this theory. It tested this theory that things that are harder and contain contradictions and conflicts in multiple sources teach us more. and what they found was that that is true. Friction in learning promotes deeper understanding and intelligence. One way to practice that, the 30-minute rule. Before you commit to AI, before you say I'm an AI, this chat, TBT, this, before I'm going to ask chat,
基本上就是“离开这个我什么也做不了”。当它被用于复杂的决策或大量的思考时，它有导致“权威偏差”的风险。你知道的，因为上面说这是这样的，所以它一定是对的。这也导致我们失去了很多原创性。你知道的，虽然我在自己的生活中尽量避免使用人工智能，但我也并不愚蠢，因为基于我的价值观，我知道我们很多人都会使用它。关键在于有意识地使用它，因为你希望自己清楚代价是什么。水、能源、大脑税。我认为这把我们带到了我们的第三个技巧，那就是限制你每天允许使用它的频率。
commit to 30 minutes of searching. Listen, AI will always be there. But this is about values. Do you value convenience or do you value deep learning and intelligence? do you want to be someone who can only do things quickly or someone who can engage deeply independently? And it's honestly up to you. You have free will. But you just have to acknowledge the consequences of being AI dependent here. Secondly, question whether using AI is absolutely necessary in a specific circumstance. And question how much time it's actually going to save. I think we could all benefit from using AI less.
这是我的好朋友莉兹（Lizzie）常做的事。她不想剥夺自己享受人工智能带来的效率好处的权利，特别是自从她在一家要求极高的企业环境中工作。每个人都在使用人工智能的辅助。但她所做的是将自己限制在每天三次搜索，因为保持她的创造力和原创思维能力敏锐是她的首要任务。她把它当作工具来用，这本就是它应该被使用的方式——找出适合你的公式。技巧四，注意它何时正在取代人类的来源。再次强调，我不会否认人工智能在某些方面非常惊艳。但它绝对不
So just be selective with what you use it for. I think small tasks like knowing the weather or replying to an email, you can probably do that yourself. In fact, it's probably a good thing if you do. A lot of AI researchers will tell you the best use of AI is not minute tasks. It's also not complex tasks. It's process tasks that reduce cognitive load but still require human reasoning, abstraction, and thoughts. So examples of this, formatting, structuring, outlining, searching. When AI is used for micro-tasks, it risks learned helplessness.
惊艳的地方在于给你提供个人建议、关系建议、治疗建议，当它告诉你如何回复别人的短信、如何与另一个人沟通时——这绝不是我们应该使用人工智能的方式。我认为这是神圣不可侵犯的，那就是能够解决我们之间的问题，能够沟通、敞开心扉并彼此学习。那一刻如果被机器取代，好吧，我只是觉得所有的救赎都无望了，因为同理心将被我们视为是如此无足轻重，以至于可以被卸载。所以这些就是我认为我们需要用来在人工智能世界中保持脚踏实地的技巧。此外，只要让自己感到无聊，让自己发挥创造力，确保你继续
Basically, I can't do anything without this. When it's used for complex decisions or large amounts of thinking, it risks authority bias. You know, it's said this is the case, so it must be true. And it also causes us to lose a lot of originality. You know, I'm not stupid as much as I try and avoid AI in my own life, because my values, I know a lot of us will use it. It's about using it consciously because you know hopefully what the cost is. The water, the energy, the brain tax. And I think this brings us to our third tip, which is to limit how often you're allowed to use it per day.
去发掘那些让你感到身为人类的特质，我认为这只会让我们感觉更加积极。它会让我们对自我、对我们还活着、有感知力且身为人类这一事实感觉更加积极。而且，这也将使我们能够继续建立那些只使用人工智能的人所不具备的技能。我认为这会赋予你一种优势，这种优势在一个高度以人工智能为中心的时代将变得更加重要。富有创造力、成为发散性思维者、进行广泛思考、特立独行，这将成为人工智能世界中的下一个最大技能。所以如果你具备了这些，老实说，我对你的未来感到乐观。
This is something my good friend Lizzie does. she doesn't want to deny herself the efficiency benefits of AI, especially since she works in a, I was going to say where she works. She works in a corporate environment that is very demanding. And everyone is assisted by AI. But what she does is she limits herself to three searches a day because it's a priority for her to keep her creative and original thinking skills sharp. She uses it as a tool, which is what it should be used as, just find the formula that works for you. Tip number four, notice when it's replacing human sources as well. Again, I'm not going to deny that AI isn't amazing for some things. What it's definitely not
这是我的好朋友莉兹经常做的事。她不想剥夺自己使用人工智能带来的效率提升，特别是她在这样一个地方工作——我本来想说她在哪工作。她在一家要求非常高的企业环境里工作。每个人都在使用人工智能辅助。但她的做法是，她把每天的搜索次数限制在三次，因为保持她创造性和原创性思维能力的敏锐度是她的首要任务。她把人工智能当作一种工具来使用，这正是它应该被使用的方式，只要找到适合你的方法就行。第四个小贴士，注意人工智能何时也在替代人类资源。再次强调，我不会否认人工智能在某些方面非常神奇。但它绝对不是
amazing for is giving you personal advice, relationship advice, therapy advice, when it's telling you how to answer someone's text, when it's telling you how to communicate with another person, that is not how we should be using AI. That is something that I think is sacred, being able to solve problems between us, being able to communicate and be open and learn from each other. The moment that is replaced by a machine, like, I just think all help is lost because empathy is then empathy is then something that we are saying is so unimportant it can be offloaded. So those are the tips I think we need to kind of stay grounded in AI. Also just let yourself be bored, let yourself be creative, make sure that you are continuing
神奇的地方在于给你提供个人建议、恋爱建议、心理咨询建议，当它告诉你怎么回复别人的短信，当它告诉你怎么与另一个人沟通时，这绝对不是我们应该使用人工智能的方式。我认为这是神圣的，能够解决我们之间的问题，能够沟通、敞开心扉并互相学习。当这一切被机器取代时，我只是觉得所有的帮助都消失了，因为同理心就变成了我们认为无足轻重、可以被外包的东西。所以这些就是我认为我们需要在人工智能时代保持理智的小贴士。另外，让自己无聊一会儿，让自己发挥创造力，确保你仍在持续
to tap into what makes. you feel human, I think that will just make us feel more positive. It will make us feel more positive about ourselves and about the fact that we are alive and sentient and human. And also, it will allow us to keep building skills that people who only use AI won't have. And I think that gives you an edge that it's going to become even more important in a very AI-centric world. Being creative, being a divergent thinker, thinking broadly, being eccentric, that is going to be the next biggest skill in an AI world. So if you've got those, I honestly, I feel positive for your future.
挖掘那些让你感受到自己是人类的东西，我认为这只会让我们感觉更积极。它会让我们对自我以及我们是活生生的、有感知力的人类这一事实感到更积极。而且，这也将使我们能够继续培养那些只使用人工智能的人所不具备的技能。我认为这会赋予你一种优势，这种优势在一个高度以人工智能为核心的世界里将变得更加重要。富有创造力、具备发散性思维、思考广泛、特立独行，这将是人工智能时代最重要的技能。所以如果你具备这些，老实说，我对你的未来感到乐观。
I think you're going to be just fine. Thank you, as always, to our researcher Libby Colbert for her help with this episode. Thank you if you have made it this far. If you have and you are listening on Spotify, leave a little computer. cuter emoji down below so I know you're a loyal listener and thank you as always for for being here till the end I really appreciate it I hope you enjoyed this episode I hope it I didn't come off too strong but also I'm down for a discussion so if you have further thoughts DM me email me however you want to get in touch you can follow us on Instagram at that psychology podcast you can
我想你会没事的。一如既往地感谢我们的研究员莉比·科尔伯特对本期节目的帮助。感谢你能听到这里。如果你听到了这里并且正在使用Spotify收听，请在下方留下一个可爱的电脑表情符号，让我知道你是一位忠实的听众，也一如既往地感谢你陪伴我们到最后，我真的很感激。希望你喜欢这期节目，希望我没有表现得过于强势，但我也很乐意进行讨论，所以如果你有进一步的想法，请私信我、发邮件给我，或者通过任何你想联系我的方式。你可以在Instagram上关注我们，账号是that psychology podcast，你还可以
also follow us on substack and TikTok and if you are listening and you want to watch the podcast we are on Netflix so you can tune in over there if you have a yet and if you're in the U.S. and Canada. But until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself, be AI conscious. We will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
在Substack和TikTok上关注我们。如果你正在收听并想观看视频播客，我们在Netflix上播出了，如果你还没看过并且身在美国和加拿大，可以去那边收看。但在此之前，请注意安全，保持善良，对自我温柔以待，保持AI意识。我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立心理韧性、健身和韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%? That's TWO%. On the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. In 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we
收听《2%》？是数字2%。在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at it》播客中。1979年对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集，我们都会选择一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何
survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
挺过来的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年真是疯狂的一年。那是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《look back at it》。嘿，大家最近怎么样？
You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit up? armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a
你正在收听的是由你最喜爱的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间旨在探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一身盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在IHard radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这段怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭开一个
disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, the lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，女同性恋者。迈克尔·曼奇尼。我简直震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这就是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他绝不能就此逃脱。他会得到应有的惩罚。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。这是一个IHeart播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。